we're about to enter the busy fall  season of video game releases and there  are free titles headed our way next week  I'm Tony this is a game spot news update  and this is your PlayStation Plus lineup  for September PS Plus subscribers on ps4  are getting the dark souls like Lords of  the Fallen they're also getting  gamespot's own 2012 game of the year  journey which will also be available on  ps3 ps3 is also getting the trippy  forest exploring game datura and prince  of persia the forgotten sands PS vita is  getting the visual novel amnesia  memories finally the action-adventure  badland is coming to all three platforms  any of those sound good to you the new  playstation plus games will be available  Tuesday September 6th until then you can  pick up August free games including  rebel galaxy and Yakuza 5 to keep up  with all the PlayStation news including  their big event next week you're already  in the right place  you